bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée au
trailer de moon knight mais avant ça je
tenais quand même à vous souhaiter une
très belle année voilà 2022 s'annonce
comme une année fournie en termes de
films et de séries donc compter sur moi
en tout cas pour être présent tout au
long de l'année vous fournir de belles
théories bon revenons sur moon knight le
trailer annonce une série qui a l'air
quand même vachement cool franchement il
ya une très bonne vague qui s'en dégage
et j'aime beaucoup j'ai plutôt hâte
franchement alors pour rappel moon
knight ces six épisodes et du coup
nouveauté la date de la sortie de la
série a été annoncée ce sera pour le 30
mars je pense personnellement que le but
derrière et de coller avec la sortie de
doctor strange 2 en mai tout comme nous
avions eu hawkeye dont la fin sortait
approximativement même temps que spider
man noir ou par rapport maintenant au
contenu du trailer de moonlight nous
allons devoir refaire un peul origin
story de ce nouveau héros incarné par
oscar isaac car il ya quand même pas mal
d'informations déjà le trailer s'ouvre
sur le personnage en train de s'amuser à
se lancer un rubik's cube mélanger je
trouve ici l'idée intéressante car le
rubik's cube semble interpréter la
complexité que symbolise le héros moon
knight effectivement de son vrai nom
marc spector notre protagoniste possède
quelque chose de particulier c'est qu'il
est atteint d'un trouble dissociatif de
l'identité
pour faire simple marque possède
plusieurs identités plusieurs
personnages vivent à travers lui dans
les comics il peut par moment se
présenter comme steven grant un riche
play-boy marque spector sa première
identité est un mercenaire ou encore
jeff klauk lit un chauffeur de taxi sans
oublier évidemment l'identité une
nouvelle en tant que moon knight par le
biais de comme sow le dieu de la lune et
de la vengeance dans le trailer marque
ne semble pas savoir qu'il est atteint
de ce trouble on nous le présente comme
steven grant le fameux riche play-boy
ici réécrit en tant que vendeur dans un
musée ce qui va être intéressant c'est
que je pense que nous allons évoluer
même temps que notre héros de par les
comics nous savons que marc spector est
la principale identité du protagoniste
le fait qui nous est présenté comme
steven grant avec des potentiels
problèmes de sommeil nous traduite ici
qui ne semble plus se souvenir de son
passé et de son vécu en tant que marque
spector et qu'en plus de ça il n'a pas
conscience qu'ils possèdent plusieurs
identités donc je pense que tout comme
le héros plus nous avancerons dans la
série plus nous découvrirons sur le
passé du personnage je vous avoue que ce
qui m'a le plus interpellé par rapport à
ça c'est la scène où il se retrouve avec
quelqu'un au téléphone avec un numéro
inconnu il est évident pour moi qu'il
s'agit de marlène iron dans les comics
marlène et la petite amie de mark
spector et je précise bien de marque
spector c'est la fille du docteur al ron
un grand archéologue alors qu'ils
étaient mercenaires marque accompagné
rôle bochmann pour un raid afin de voler
les découvertes du docteur sauf que
buchmann n'est pas quelqu'un de tendre
et au moment du raid décident de
liquider absolument tout le monde marque
dans un élan d'héroïsme tentera de
s'interposer notamment pour sauver
marlène de la tuerie sauf qu'il se fera
tuer la suite vous la connaissez marque
hummer au pied de la statue de qu'en
dessous le dieu de la lune et de la
vengeance et ce dernier réanimera marque
en échange du fait qu'il devienne le
moonlight le champion entre guillemets
de qu'en dessous du coup pour revenir au
coup de téléphone la femme au bout du
fil et la seule personne du trailer à
l'appeler marque cette dernière semble
même choqué que marc soit toujours en
vie et notre héros semble très
interpellé car lui ne comprend pas
pourquoi il se fait appeler marque donc
comme je disais il s'agit pour moi
forcément de marlène qui a retrouvé la
trace de marque et comme je vous
l'expliquais un peu plus tôt marc ne
semble pas avoir conscience de son
trouble de l'identité du fait que le
numéro soit en inconnu et qu'ils ne se
reconnaissent pas quand il se fait
appeler marque il met tout ça sur le dos
des problèmes de sommeil comme quoi ils
n'arrivent plus à différencier les rêves
et la réalité mais au final ce ne sont
pas des rêves mais simplement les
souvenirs de son ancienne vie sous une
autre identité sans oublier le
traumatisme qu'il a dû avoir dû à sa
mort avant de renaître grâce à qu'en
dessous et justement parlons un peu de
com sous on en avait parlé dans une
précédente vidéo mais en soi marque est
une aubaine pour le dieu de la lune
puisque grâce à ce trouble dissociatif
de l'identité il peut manipuler marque
sans que ce dernier ne s'en rende
vraiment compte l'identité de moonlight
ce fonds parmi les autres et par rapport
à cannes sous il va falloir que nous
parlions de l'antagoniste teasé dans le
trailer car il y a des éléments plutôt
intéressant et anneaux que son lycée
nous jouer un vilain méconnu de
moonlight j'ai nommé arthur euros alors
cela peut sembler perturbant pour
certains car évidemment nous pouvions
nous attendre à la présence d'un push
man qui est complètement à l'origine de
l'existence du moon knight et premier
ennemi de marque spector mais vous allez
voir que le choix d' arthur n'est pas si
mal arthur est un docteur un peu
particulier c'est un bon savant fou
comme on en a déjà connus mais sa
particularité c'est qu'il est un expert
en médecine notamment grâce à sa fameuse
théorie qui lui a presque rapporté le
prix nobel de médecine j'ai nommé la
théorie de la douleur ce qui est
intéressant avec ce vilain c'est
qu'étant donné qu'il est un médecin
spécialisé dans la douleur et que mark
est atteint de troubles dont il n'a pas
encore conscience et bien ce dernier va
permettre à notre héros de se découvrir
de se comprendre et d'avancer mais cela
ne s'arrête pas là et c'est ici que l'on
va pouvoir ramener en dessous marvel
aime beaucoup les fusions de personnages
alors je le cite en exemple à chaque
fois mais c'est le plus pertinent je
trouve dans la série law qui nous avons
fait face à une fusion du directeur du
tva remains et immo russe une évolution
de kango conquérant donc ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que je suspecte marvel
faire une autre fusion de personnages
pour la série moonlight et notamment par
rapport à ce vilain je m'explique arthur
euros en tant que vilain j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas mais en réalité ce
n'est pas du tout suffisant pourquoi car
arthur est un bon vilain pour marc mais
pas réellement pour moon knight ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que en tant
que moonlight cela veut dire que quand
sous le dieu de la lune est impliquée
dans le conflit sans oublier également
que marc spector sous son identité de
moonlight devient beaucoup plus sombre
est beaucoup plus fort donc voilà il y
en guise ou roche concernant le
personnage d'arthur euros et c'est là
que la fusion intervient déjà dans le
premier synopsis de la série il était
fait mention que marc et ses identités
allait se retrouver dans un conflit
impliquant les dieux d'égypte dans une
époque moderne par rapport à la
chronologie du trailer on nous a
démontré que marc a déjà vécu sa mort et
qu'il a déjà été ressuscité parc en
dessous notamment par le biais du fameux
coup de téléphone de marlène et les
apparitions du dieu de la lune ce qui
signifie qu'il a déjà son identité de
moonlight dès le début de la série sauf
que vous vous en doutez toute l'intrigué
va aller crescendo notre protagoniste va
mener sa petite vie en tant que steven
grant puis va prendre conscience petit à
petit qui se passe des choses bizarres
avant de prendre pleinement conscience
de ce qu'il est réellement mais pour ça
cela veut dire que quand dessous va
faire se réveiller le moon knight qui
est en marque spector sauf que je doute
fortement que comme sous va faire appel
au moonlight juste pour un médecin un
petit peu fou il va faire appel au
moonlight car un autre dieu d'égypte est
une menace et on en revient la vidéo je
vous avais parlé de l'oeuvre mais pour
moi il ya de grandes chances que la
série nous propose une interprétation
sun king le roi soleil une fusion de
personnages entre arturo le médecin un
petit peu fou et du coup le sun king le
roi soleil pour rappel le roi soleil est
en gros le champion damon ras le dieu
égyptien affiliés au soleil et le père
de qu'en dessous avec qui il possède une
grande rivalité en même temps la lune le
soleil voilà c'est cohérent et c'est là
que c'est intéressant jusque avec cette
fusion arturo pourrait être le vilain de
marque spector tandis que la condition
de roi soleil d'arthur pourrait être le
vilain de moonlight et on comprendrait
pourquoi qu'en dessous fait appel à son
chevalier d'ailleurs arthur nous est
présenté sans barbe sans moustache et
avec les cheveux longs dans le trailer
mais pendant un très court passage nous
le voyons avec les cheveux courts et une
barbe et une moustache et là bizarrement
il ressemble beaucoup plus à ce à quoi
ressemble le sun king dans les comics
d'ailleurs éléments potentiels qui
pourraient appuyer également la présence
damon rats dans la série c'est que le
dieu du soleil est normalement la
première divinités égyptiennes à exister
dans l'univers à un moment donné nous
voyons moon knight en train d'achever ce
qui semblerait être anobli ce compliqué
de définir si c'est vraiment lui mais il
ressemble beaucoup au dieu de la mort
quand même étant donné que dans
l'échelle hiérarchique des dieux
égyptiens de marvel anubis est très loin
en dessous damon rats ils pourraient ici
est renvoyé comme un soldat du dieu du
soleil pour affronter son fils khonsou
permettant ainsi d'avoir dans le récit
un premier redoutable adversaire qui
servira d'introduction au moonlight
avant de passer au boss final des
divinités une fois expérimenté le dieu
du soleil amon ra
et je pense que nous allons nous arrêter
ici il y avait pas mal de choses à dire
sur le trailer moon knight s'annonce
clairement comme une série très cool
mais bon n'oublions pas que c'est une
origin story les six épisodes vont
passer très vite il va falloir bien
fournir l'histoire de marc spector parce
qu'elle est quand même assez complexe
sans oublier évidemment tout le concept
des divinités égyptiennes avec comme
sous amon ra etc je sais que beaucoup
attendent ce héros notamment par rapport
à sa liaison avec blade ou encore sa
présence parmi les midnight sun ce mais
personnellement je m'attends plus à ça
pour pourquoi pas une scène post
générique
un peu comme l'a fait eternalz qui a
réuni déjà blade et dan woods man qui
font tous les deux partie des midnight
sun ce de souvenirs et du coup une night
se rajoutera très certainement par la
suite enfin voilà j'espère que la vidéo
vous aura plu si c'est le cas vous le
savez n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir
avec un petit pouce bleus n'hésitez pas
non plus à me laisser un petit
commentaire concernant le trailer ci
vous à hype et ou pas ou si vous avez
des attentes concernant la série c'est
toujours des sujets très intéressant moi
en tout cas je suis clairement hype
n'oubliez pas en tout cas de vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les
prochaines sorties écoutez cet argot
rock que le lay rares soit avec vous
allez ciao thoune
[Musique]